SOUTH OF THE WHITE HOUSE, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MEANWHILE, LET’S BRING IN CAYLEE
KAYLEIGH McENANY, WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SEC TAXER SHE’S ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD TO JOIN YOU, STEVE.
STEVE: OKAY.
SO WHEN THE PRESIDENT SIGNED
THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER, DOES HE
REALLY INTEND TO IMPLEMENT THOSE
THINGS, OR IS THIS JUST ANOTHER
ONE OF THOSE NEGOTIATION TACTICS
THAT DONALD TRUMP IS FAMOUS FOR?
>> OH, HE MOST CERTAINLY INTENDS
TO IMPLEMENT THE FOUR EXECUTIVE
ORDERS PERTAINING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE, STUDENT
LOANS, THE PAYROLL TAX HOLIDAY
AND EVICTIONS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED RELIEF
AND, YOU KNOW, CHUCK SCHUMER,
IT’S FUNNY LISTENING TO HIM
THERE TALK ABOUT THESE EXECUTIVE
ORDERS AS NOT BEING ENOUGH,
WELL, WHAT HAVE DEMOCRATS PUT
FORWARD?
PRECISELY NOTHING EXCEPT
REJECTING AT LEAST ON TWO
OCCASIONS A $600 KLEENEX E
TENSION OF UNEMPLOYMENT -- CLEAN
EXTENSION OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ACTED IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE’S BEST
INTERESTS.
AINSLEY: THERE WAS VIOLENCE AND
LOOTING IN CHICAGO, WE’RE SEEING
THAT ACTUALLY ON THE MAGNIFICENT
MILE, RIOTS IN PORTLAND, WHAT’S
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO DO ABOUT
THAT TODAY?
>> YEAH, SO THE PRESIDENT HAS
PUT IN PLACE OPERATION LEGEND
WHICH HAS SO FAR SUCCEEDED IN
ARRESTING 250 INDIVIDUALS AND
CHARGING 250 INDIVIDUALS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY PER TALK ABOUTING
TO -- PERTAINING TO CIVIL
UNREST.
BUT WHAT HAS BEEN SO INTERESTING
TO SEE IN PORTLAND IS FINALLY,
IT TOOK 70 NIGHTS, BUT FINALLY
YOU HAVE THE LIBERAL PORTLAND
MAYOR WHEELER SAY SAYING THAT IF
YOU LOCK POLICE OFFICERS IN A
BUILDING, INTEND TO TRAP THEM IN
THERE, USE AN ACCELERANT TO
COMMIT ARSON, YOU ARE COMMITTING
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
IT TOOK A FULL 70 DAYS FOR THE
LIBERAL MAYOR TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT’S AN UNACCEPTABLE STATUS
QUO AND THESE AREN’T JUST
PEACEFUL DEMONSTRATIONS AS HE
TRIED TO SHOW WHEN HE WALKED
AMONG THESE RIOTERS.
BRIAN: SO ONE OF THE BIG STORIES
AROUND THE WORLD REMAINS
COVID-19 AND THE SURGE BACK IN
MELBOURNE, IT’S COMING BACK IN
GERMANY AND SPAIN, COMING BACK A
LITTLE BIT IN SOUTH KOREA AND
JAPAN.
BUT NOT LIKE IT IS HERE.
AND IT GOES BACK TO TESTING.
NOW, WHEN YOU SEE THE CDC
EVIDENTLY IS COMING UP WITH A
SALIVA TEST, WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US ABOUT THAT?
AND DO YOU AGREE WITH SOME WHO
SAY IF THESE LABS CAN’T GET A
TEST BACK TO AN AMERICAN CITIZEN
IN LESS THAN THREE DAYS, THEY
SHOULDN’T GET PAID FOR IT
BECAUSE THEY’RE USELESS?
>> I’LL LEAVE IT TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC OF
PROVISION, BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY
IS THIS: DR. BIRX AND OUR TEAM
HERE HAVE BEEN HARD AT WORK TO
DO POOL TESTING, TO REDUCE THE
TESTING TURN-AROUND TIME, AND WE
HAVE SEEN SOME SUCCESS THERE.
WE IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
BEEN NUMBER ONE IN TESTING IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD BY A LONG SHOT,
MORE THAN 65 MILLION TESTS
COMPARING THAT NUMBER TO INDIA
TO AROUND 18 MILLION.
WE’VE DONE EXTRAORDINARY WORK,
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT NEW
TESTS, BRIAN,ING LIKE A SALIVA
TEST, WE HAVE MORE THAN A
HUNDRED EMERGENCY USE AUTHORS
EXPLORING EVEN MORE TESTING
CAPABILITY ABOVE THE ABBOTT TEST
AND THE RAPID TURN-AROUND TEST
AND THE OTHER TESTS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE ON THE
COMMERCIAL MARKET.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, KAYLEIGH,
SOMETHING I WAS READING
YESTERDAY TRYING TO CATCH UP
AFTER A WEEK AWAY WITH, I’M
SHOCKED AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING INTO FIGHTS OVER
MASKS.
I MEAN, THERE WAS SOME GUY WHO
PUNCHED, I THINK, A 75-YEAR-OLD
GUY, PARTIALLY DISABLED VET, IN
THE JAW AND BROKE HIS JAW
BECAUSE THE GUY SAID, HEY, YOU
KNOW, YOUR GIRLFRIEND ISN’T
WEARING A MASK.
WHERE DOES THE PRESIDENT STAND
ON ENCOURAGING PEOPLE -- DON’T
GET INTO A FIGHT ABOUT IT.
EITHER THEY’RE GOING TO WEAR A
MASK OR THEY’RE NOT.
>> YEAH, NO ONE SHOULD BE FIGHT
OVER THIS.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING IS DOING
WHAT IS PATRIOTIC WHICH IS WHEN
YOU CAN’T SOCIALLY DISTANCE,
WEAR A MASK.
I WAS WITH THE PRESIDENT LAST
WEEK WHEN HE WORE A MASK WHEN HE
COULDN’T SOCIALLY DISTANCE.
HE’S DONE IT SEVERAL TIMES.
THAT’S WHERE HE STANDS, IT’S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
IF YOU’RE STANDING CLOSE TO
SOMEONE AND NO ONE SHOULD BE
FIGHTING OVER IT, NEVERTHELESS.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S THE DEAL ON THE
RAPID TEST BECAUSE I KNOW SOME
FRIENDS WHO STOOD IN LINE FOR A
LONG TIME, THEY HAD TO TRAVEL TO
GET IN LINE TO GET THESE TESTS,
I KNOW SOME OTHER PEOPLE --
THERE ARE ONLY, LIKE, THREE
CLINICSES ON LONG ISLAND WHO ARE
DOING THIS.
PEOPLE WANT THE RAPID TEST TO
KNOW IF THEY NEED TO GO BACK TO
WORK OR IF THEY NEED TO
QUARANTINE.
WHAT’S THE LATEST ON GETTING
MORE RAPID TESTS OUT THERE SO
PEOPLE DON’T HAVE TO WAIT IN
LONG LINES?
>> YES, IT’S IMPORTANT.
THE END RAPID TESTS ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE NATION,
BUT WE HAVE PRIORITIZED MAKING
SURE THEY GET TO PLACES WHERE WE
HAVE VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES LIKE
OUR NURSING HOMES WHERE WE’VE
PUSHED A LOT OF THE TESTING TO
PROTECT AMERICA’S SENIORS.
BUT THERE IS EVEN IN OUR TESTING
SYSTEM AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS
EXCESS TESTING CAPACITY BECAUSE
SOME OF THE TESTS THAT DO TAKE A
FEW DAYS ARE NOT FULLY BEING
UTILIZED.
THERE’S EXCESS CAPACITY IN THE
SYSTEM IS, BUT YOU’RE RIGHT THAT
SURGINGED RAPID TEST WHERE WE
CAN IS IMPORTANT, SPECIFICALLY
IN OUR NURSING HOMES.
BRIAN: SO CHINA HAS SANCTIONED,
IN THE RESPONSE TO OUR
SANCTIONING SOME OF OUR
LAWMAKERS, THEY’VE SANCTIONED 11
OF OURS INCLUDING MARCO RUBIO,
TED CRUZ, TOM COTTON, PAT TOOMEY
AND WE HAVE ALSO ANOTHER
CONGRESSMAN FROM SOUTH JERSEY OF
NO TRUMP OFFICIALS.
WHAT’S YOUR REACTION TO CHINA’S
REACTION TO OUR SANCTIONING OF
THEM?
>> YEAH.
CHINA STANDS ON NOTICE BECAUSE
THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
UNMISTAKEABLE IN STANDING UP TO
CHINA.
YOU’VE SEEN HIM WITH THE PHASE
TWO CHINA DEAL, PUSHING THAT
DEAL THROUGH LIKE NO OTHER
PRESIDENT COULD OR HAS IN
HISTORY.
HE’S TAKEN ACTION, SANCTIONING
AGAINST THE ABUSIVE TREATMENT OF
THE UIGHURS, NO LONGER
RECOGNIZING HONG KONG’S
AUTONOMOUS STATUS BECAUSE OF
CHINESE INTERVENTION.
SO THIS PRESIDENT STOOD UP
MISTAKEABLE.
CHINA MAY TRY TO GET HIM BACK AS
NOTED, BUT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
STOOD FIRM AGAINST CHINA, AND
HE’LL CONTINUE TO.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.